-♪♪ Mother Daughter Challenge ♪♪
-Now I'm going to read you
questions about each other,
and you'll try to write down
the same answer.
-Okay.
-Simple as that.
It should be very, very easy.
Yeah.
And you'll probably
write the same thing.
-Hopefully.
-Yeah, of course.
-You know I can see.
-Oh. See?
Oh, no cheating.
I love that.
All right, good.
Here we go.
-Earnest, I'm earnest.
-All right, very good.
Yara, what's the one thing
your mom says
more than anything else?
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
No profanity.
-No.
-Oh, my goodness.
♪♪♪♪
-Excuse my handwriting, okay.
-How much did you write?
-Ready?
-All right, ready?
Yara, what'd you write?
-Homeboy/homegirl.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
Oh, she wrote "homegirl"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
How do you --
-I never remember people's na--
I never remember people's names.
So I'm like,
"Yo, you know homegirl?"
[ Laughter ]
And she's like, "Who?"
-"Homegirl -- homeboy/homegirl."
-Like 90% of the time,
I know exactly
who you're talking about.
-Right, there's 10%
where you're like,
"I don't know
what you're talking about."
[ Laughter ]
-Homeboy, homegirl...
By the way, I'm Jimmy,
just so you remember.
[ Laughter ]
-I'll remember.
-Okay, good.
-We saw homeboy at --
No, we saw homeboy
at the Met Gala.
You did see homeboy
-And tonight,
we're on homeboy's show.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Keri, what is
Yara's one secret --
Oh, sorry --
one desert-island album?
So you have one album --
-The only thing she can take.
-The only thing
she can listen to.
-I have to have
the name of the album?
-Yes.
-Okay.
Do you have to say the artist?
-Yeah, I think so.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-I just asked the judges,
they said yeah.
-I feel like this is easy,
but then, that may make it hard.
-Okay. Ready?
-All right.
Wait. Let's go.
-Okay.
-Keri, what did you write first?
"Blonde," Frank Ocean.
-What'd you write?
-Whoa!
Frank!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Wow!
Oh, my gosh!
You guys --
-We spend
a lot of time together.
-You guys already won.
I mean, this is fantastic.
This is the greatest ever.
The last question right here.
Ready?
-Okay, okay.
-This is fantastic.
I love that.
-I keep closing my sharpie,
okay.
-All right, ready?
Yara --
Yara, what celebrity would your
mom most want you to date?
[ Audience Oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Please write "Homeboy."
[ Laughter ]
Come on, just do it for me.
No, no.
Okay.
[ Clock ticking ]
What celebrity would your mom
most want you to date?
You're both writing a long...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
You're both writing
something very long.
-Wait. I'm not done.
-All right, wait.
-What are you writing?
-Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, goodness!
-Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
All right.
-Okay, I'm ready.
[ Drumroll ]
-Okay.
-Yara, what did you write?
-It may not make much sense
but I was asking
if I could platonically date
James Baldwin.
Like if we were in the same era
or decade?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know if that's po--
"Any celebrity concerned
about the environment so--"
-Or sociopolitical climate.
-See?
-Wait, wait, there's more.
-"And loves your mom."
Oh, see?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the right answer
right there.
Or James Baldwin, platonically.
Yara and Keri Shahidi,
everybody.
The "Black-ish" season finale
airs tomorrow
at 9:00 p.m., on ABC.